we didn't know what the next step would
be we knew we hadn't got an SOS off
we knew that we were 200 miles west of
the Galapagos Islands
we had no water
and no food as we thought then
[Music]
I was born in the middle of England
Staffordshire
and we were farmers
so we we ran the hill farm for the first
16 years of my life and my dad was a
former sea captain and my mum was a
nurse
from that she'd worked in Hong Kong and
the Middle East we lived in a market
town and our whole lives revolved around
farming but we used to listen to my
dad's stories of when he was at Sea and
um you know Sailors can always spin a
good yard so we used to sit enthralled
with his stories it was in the 1968 that
uh
there was around the world yacht race
sailing around the world in those days
was an adventure all in itself because
there was no electronic navigation there
were no electronic um
safety AIDS it was you were on your own
basically my brother Neil said Daddy's a
sailor why don't we sail around the
world like a throwaway comment
but that that really sparked an idea in
dougal's head my dad's head
he was just uh you know living hand to
mouth and he considered his children to
be very
um uh unworldly unworldly because
um we were in this sort of rural setting
and he thought why not
somehow from that little seed a plan
grew that we would sail around the world
and it seems a little bit crazy now
looking back but it seemed very normal
to us as we were growing up first of all
we had to find a boat so we spent a lot
of time looking for about two years to
find the right sort of boat
and I think it was my mum who found uh
what was advertised as a world gurgler
I think it was probably
July or August of 1970.
we we met up in Falmouth and that was
going to be our new life can you just
explain who was on the boat so there was
my mum and dad then there was my sister
and myself we were sort of five years
older than the Twins and then the twins
so we had a birth each it was a sixth
birthday yacht with a saloon and a
galley and uh
um a Folk Soul so
um 45 foot long that sort of length
it was January by the time the wind
shifted to the right quarter that
enabled us to set sail around the world
wherever that was you know we were so
naive when I think back to it we had no
idea where we were going and um we took
a Lisbon wherever that is you know and
Lisbon was going to be our first foreign
port
if you've got no experience of yards
sailing on a yacht sounds very very
exotic when it's in the harbor tied up
alongside looks very nice people come
down say what a nice yacht they've got
no idea what it's like on a yacht at Sea
there are things to bang your head on
there are things to fall over there are
cleats to stub your toes on there are
words new words a new vocabulary that
you've never heard of before you know we
sail across the Atlantic it took us 33
days to get across the Atlantic it's the
same time it took Christopher Columbus
or almost 300 years before us and you
know this was more like it this was what
we dreamed of calm seas
tropical weather
Discovery a voyage of Discovery in one
of those Many Adventures that I referred
to we would rescue the fishermen
uh who was adrift in his fishing boat
and in a sort of really strange setup we
towed him under sail we towed his
fishing boat with us under sail to
Nassau in the Bahamas as a reward one of
the sort of
uh rotarians of the uh of the local
Society
offered as a gift from his dive shop of
any present that we would like to have
and my sister fell in love with the
with his son
and suddenly announced that she would no
longer be coming with us on the trip she
was going to call it a day there
and she was going to live with Jeff and
that was a shock to us all and we we
sailed off to the San Blas Islands which
are just to the east of Panama in Panama
we picked up a student you know we could
pick up people who were looking to
partake in the same Adventure and help
pay for the voyage so Robin Williams
joined us after some sort of extended
cruising there we sailed through the
canal
and we were then in the Pacific Ocean so
the next leg of our trip had started
really once we got through the canal
there was no going back we were on our
way to Australia New Zealand
we had a very rough sort of departure
from Galapagos because the wind was
quite strong four six
and the waves were quite large and we
were in a reach which is the on the beam
the wind was on the beam and it um made
the boat roll quite heavily but we were
used to it you know by then I mean when
I think back to how we left Falmouth we
were 100 seasoned Sailors we could sail
the boat
in in Pitch Black uh with uh we knew the
rules of the road we knew you know we
knew how to sail
well we were 200 miles west of Cape
Espinoza and the Galapagos Islands it
was quartered quarter past ten I think
but I think dual recorded it's 10
o'clock
and um he was working his sight out and
uh cytus an observation of the sun to
get a fix of the boat's position
and
he did he put a coffee on the coffee
particulars are on the stove and um
a little did he know that he was never
going to drink that coffee
because the events of the next few few
seconds we're going to change all our
lives forever
I was up on the in the cockpit with my
brother Sandy he was at the whale
and uh Robin had gone to bed because
he'd done the night watch and um
suddenly
there was an ear splintering crash
and the boat jolted three times and
there were three crashes one after the
other bang bang bang like that and the
boat jolted heavily it was lifted out of
the water and she settled back into the
water and it felt like we'd gone around
at high speed
and I poke my head down the hatch to say
to my dad what what is that what was
that
and I noticed he was up to his ankles in
water
and I asked him what he was doing
like didn't he know that was dangerous I
thought he'd opened a Seacock or
something like that
and he said where's this water coming
from
and then there was a big noise behind me
over on the left-hand side and a three
killer whales appeared following us like
if you can get it in your mind a big
daddy one a little baby one in between
and their mummy one on their Far Side
and the the big one the Big Daddy one
had his head split open and blood was
pouring out into the sea
we'd come through the doldrums
about two months before
and we'd had a big whale baleen whale
tried to make love to the boat
it rubbed itself up alongside
and we thought if that whale
could mistake us for another whale for
the purpose of mating
maybe the killer whales had attacked us
for thinking we were also also thinking
that we were a whale for food purposes I
poked my head down Back Down the Hatch
Dougal and he was up to his waist in
water
and I thought
if he doesn't shut that Seacock soon you
know you have ridiculous thoughts we're
going to sink
I said dad what and he said abandon ship
and I said abandon I was petulant 18
year old you know Abandon Ship what
you're talking about you know so to
where do and I said we're not in Miami
Marina now
he said over there and I sort of first
got the first Inkling
that things had gone horribly wrong
and this wasn't supposed to be happening
I started to take the sales down and and
Google appeared briefly on the on on the
deck and said what are you doing get the
life raft over the side and I thought my
God I'm not going to wake up from this
this is really happening I've got to get
moving now I got the I I got the dinghy
over the side I tied it to the rail put
the oars in the dinghy
and uh I got the life raft over the side
which is quite heavy
and I pulled the cord in
and I remember
the raft a loud bang as the raft started
to inflate and I thought my God you know
thank thank the Lord that's happened at
least we can get into the into the raft
and then I was washed off the deck so in
that time scale probably a couple of
minutes I managed to swim
I was very frightened that the whales
were going to get us at that moment
because they were still around and um uh
that they they I kept feeling for my
legs to see if I still had them I swam
around to the raft entrance and climbed
in
and everybody was sitting there yellow
very yellow looking from the canopy
overhead
and we were all in shock about what had
just happened
and that they they thought I'd been lost
and they were very my mum and dad
especially were very sort of pleased to
see me
and they helped pull me on board and uh
we then had to sort of sit and take
stock of what had happened
and
the Twins were crying and
my mum said to them don't be frightened
and the twins said we're not crying
because we're frightened mum we're
crying because lucette's gone
So Lisa had been our home for two years
she'd been the source of Many Adventures
and now she was gone
and we we had a very uncertain future in
front of us
we didn't know what the next step would
be we knew we hadn't got an SOS off
we knew that we were 200 miles west of
the Galapagos Islands
we had no water
and no food as we thought then
and
the enormity
of what had just happened was starting
to hit us
and my mum said that we should say the
Lord's Prayer
and my I'll never forget my dad's
it was a hard man my dad Navy trained we
used to say
and he said well I don't believe in God
so I am not going to say the Lord's
Prayer
and I said to him Google can't you just
say the Lord's Prayer anyway you know I
said we might need God very soon we
might be meeting him much sooner than we
think
and he he said well you know if there is
a God don't you think he'd know that
don't listen so there's no point
pretending
but we did say the Lord's Prayer and uh
we thought that we might need some
Divine assistance
if we were to survive the next few days
ah the raft was quickly blown clear of
the uh the Rex act and then we were on
our own truly on our own I always
remember looking out at the sea
and this frigate bird flew down and a a
flying fish jumped out of the Sea and
the frigate bed just snapped it up and
flew off with it you know as if mocking
us you know and I said to my dad I said
they've got millions of years on us
and Dougal said something that was very
which was to help us in the future and
perhaps signify how we might survive
he said yes Douglas but
We've Got Brains and with brains we can
make tools and with tools we can survive
and so there were six of you on the raft
and how big was the raft well the raft
was a 10-man raft but it's for 10
sitting people
so it's not designed to be lived on
and so we we filled that space
and um we then had the dinghy which was
a three-man dinghy in the had three
thwarts and we noticed there was a
survival pack in the raft it had I think
it was
say 20 tins of water I think it was 18
actually
and it had some glucose tablets and some
biscuits
the there was some Flotsam going by and
I managed to grab this generous ale
and my mum's sewing basket which turned
out to be an absolute Treasure Trove
bits of copper wire bits of string bits
of ribbon bits of cloth and a needle and
thread and uh tools basically tools and
we didn't quite know how to use them yet
but we knew that they were valuable we
knew where we were roughly
and Dougal had come up with this plan
that I should Row the dinghy we should
empty the dinghy and I should row it to
the Galapagos Islands and raise the
alarm
I mean we did we were Sailors by then we
knew the current was two and a half
knots away from that's 50 miles a day
taking us away from the Galapagos the
wind was another 50 miles a day blowing
away the trade winds blowing us away
from Galapagos that's 100 miles a day
that's four knots I'd have to row that
boat at four knots just to stand still
there was no way I could row faster than
that
24 hours how many days would I have to
stay awake
and I remember at 18 and a half with a
very strong willed Father I remember
saying to him Dad I'm not going to do
that
that is a Fool's errand and I will die
and as a result you will die
and that was the sort of first time I'd
ever sort of said something sensible to
my dad you know that he'd listen to and
I remember him saying I'm sorry Douglas
for asking you I should never have asked
but it was the desperation that was
making me ask
and uh
we need another plan we need to make
another plan
but there was one option
and when we'd come when I go back to
that big baleen whale again
that was in the doldrums and in the
doldrums it rains heavily
and we knew we could survive without
food perhaps for quite some time but we
couldn't survive without water
so we made a plan
to sail to the center of the Pacific
Ocean try and stay in the Dolphins where
we could get a supply of water
and then sail East towards the Americas
and that somehow we might get picked up
along that route so we made a sale and
we used the oars from the raft as a boom
for the for the makeshift sale
and Google Google's idea we would sail
the uh sell the dinghy backwards Towing
the raft
so that this wind would catch the trade
winds would catch the sail and tow the
raft and that would maybe save us a
couple of days
on the way to the doldrums so every day
would count we knew that how are you
feeling dick did you have hope that you
would survive or did you no no no
desperate
I mean
we thought we were going to die anytime
anytime now
the moment of truth is going to arrive
at our doorstep
and this it'll be a wave it'll be a
whale don't forget we've just been hit
by those whales and we'd we thought
maybe maybe they would come back to us
or other whales would find us but on the
sixth day we spied the first ship from
the shipping Lane so we thought we might
see
the name of that ship was the star cook
and she sailed right pastors
and that was a very very tough moment to
take
because we realized that suddenly that
it wasn't a question of surviving till
we got rescued
that somehow we had to survive until we
got ourselves out of this mess
and we fired five flares three and
flares and two parachute flares at that
ship
and uh
I said Dad we had one one flare left I
said Dad fire it straight at the bridge
of the ship
and he said I can't do that Douglas you
may have explosions on Deck
something like that but Dougal did have
a revelation at that point
and he said we're not going to get
rescued and we can't rely on that
he said we have got to sail from here to
America
a 75 days
so and we just thought how can we
survive 75 days in this how are you
keeping your spirits up and how is the
dynamic between all of you well we
everybody has a purpose you know in a
survival story
and whilst my dad was our leader my mum
was our carer and I was the muscles
behind dougal's sort of uh leadership
and bright ideas that he came up with
Robin who was our passenger Robin
Williams he was a well-educated young
man
who hadn't got hardly any experience at
Sea only what he'd had with us
but he could talk
and boy could he talk
and boy was it good to listen to his
voice I remember saying to him Ramen
tell me about the time when you were
stuck in the bus station in Florida
that time and he he said what again you
know I say Yes again you know we just
wanted to hear each other's voices you
know
and we invented a cafe that we would um
we would open when we got home because
that gave us an excuse to talk about
food
and we talked about food an awful lot
because we hadn't got any
and the most exotic foods that you could
think of and you had to describe how you
would make them how you'd prepare them
how you would cook them how you would
serve them every detail was of great
importance
and that's how we kept our spirits up
and my dad kept a map of where he
thought we might be we had no navigation
equipment
but we knew that the sun rose in the
east and set in the West
we knew that the waves the underlying
swell was still coming from the
southeast
so we knew that as long as that was on
the uh behind us that we were headed
still headed north
and so we had an idea of where we were
and we would tick off the mileage every
day another 10 miles today another 20
miles today which was chipping away at
that overall distance that we had to
sail
and uh the Google came up with a
password which was um
survival
we're going to say that every day we're
not going to say rescue we are going to
say survival and survival is what we're
going to do I always remember saying to
my dad he was he was quite astonished at
how brutal I'd become I said I've read
somewhere that you can drink Turtle
blood you should catch one of these and
drink its blood
and you know I mean how are we going to
get the blood out of the turtle well we
had no Solutions you know
but I thought I'd catch it and I hit it
on the head with a paddle and I remember
his eyes filling up with blood as he
swam off and made good his Escape
and I thought to myself well that's a
bit silly you're gonna die anyway you
know I mean why are you trying to escape
and I remember sort of
discussing with my father how actually
we had to catch these animals hunt them
this was not this was not like a show
now the next Turtle came along and I
thought well I'm not going to let it
swim away I'm going to capture it and
lift it out of the water everybody's
jumped up on the side you know the side
of the raft and like what are you doing
Douglas you know that it was it was like
taking a box of matches into a gunpowder
at a store you know Doug will grab the
turtle and threw it out through the
forehead entrance and it was gone
so plan number two didn't work you know
a third Turtle came along
and uh I wrapped it up in the in the
lifeline there was a Lifeline attached
to the raft 100 feet of maybe 100 meters
or something and I wrapped him up in
that so he couldn't get away
and then we towed him around to the
dinghy hold him on board Dougal did that
and uh cut his throat
and
drank his blood
we cut his shallow
and he was full she was full of red meat
like steak
and eggs full of eggs like grapes like
Bunches of grapes
and we realized there's a food source
there that we could probably live off
and all we needed was more Turtles
but for now we drank the blood of this
turtle and we knew that then
that we perhaps for the first time
stood a chance of surviving
so on this on the 10th day roughly as
we'd planned it
the skies changed the clouds changed
and we noticed there was a high high
cloud
in the upper atmosphere
and Mariners know that a change in the
wind means a change in the weather
changing the sky it's changing the
weather
and we had very little water left
one or two cans and I remember saying to
my dad I said will it will it rain
tonight do you think
and he said I don't know son I don't
know
and I said well do you think it'll rain
you know I was trying to get the last
some kind of positive statement out of
it
and he said Douglas I'm not a prophet I
don't know whether it's going to rain or
not
but if it does rain we must be ready to
catch it
and I thought about that
and
and the next day the sun came out
where was the rain
beautiful weather
and as our water supplies began to
dwindle dangerously low
we perhaps realized we'd made a huge
mistake
and that we weren't actually waiting for
the rain but we were waiting to die
first
and this this assumption that it always
rained in the tolerance which is exactly
that just an assumption
three days went by
and then it rained
you know
that was a turning point in our lives
suddenly
we had this water
and we filled it all up
filled era
water cancer we filled our
um
other things that we could catch water
in
and we
we knew perhaps our plan was going to
work you know that with enough water we
could survive
and we
we sang with joy
at the because we'd managed to collect
water and
uh and we'd Court of
a few Turtles as well by then and uh
uh you know the next stage of our
survival was about to start surviving
was hard work drying food
cutting it catching turtles and when we
were sitting in the raft we were sitting
up to our chest and water into that cold
water
and that itself was was was debilitating
as to you know
[Music]
uh nearly to our deaths anyway you know
we were so cold and we had immersion
foot and we had
we had sea water boils we were covered
in sea water boils and we we were
um life was very painful you couldn't
sleep
if you did sleep your head would drop
into the sea and into the water and then
you'd wake up again and uh
you know there was one dry place on the
raft and we would take it in turns to
to sleep in that spot
you get an hour
and I always remember my mum
God bless her
giving up her turn so that we could
sleep in the dry
something we thought nothing else then
but as I advance in years I think of
that
great sacrifice she she made for us
on the 17th day the raft had had it and
at the bottom the floor dropped out of
it and we knew that we couldn't stay in
the raft any longer
and that we would have to
all get in the dinghy that would be six
of us in a three-man dinghy
Along came a turtle while we were doing
that well we were disembarking from the
raft to the dinghy and we caught this it
was a pretty big turtle as well 35 pound
turtle and we put him in the in in the
dinghy as well and the six of us and we
were still afloat
you know this this all happened over
about an hour and we watched the the
raft float away
and we thought well it got us this far
without that raft we would never have
got off to lucette in the first place
and
now this truly is on our own we're in a
boat that we could sink
we have to keep it afloat there were six
of us sitting in a three-man space
we had at least another 700 miles to go
if we were still on plan which we didn't
know for sure whether that was the case
then
one night
probably the 20th day or thereabouts
I saw the north star in the sky
and I woke my dad up and said Google
look I said this that's the North Star
now Mariners know you can only see the
North Star
from five or six degrees north of the
equator
and we had sunk two degrees south of the
Equator
that meant that we had sailed seven
degrees to the North or 420 miles
proof positive
that we were in the northern hemisphere
and that we were
on track suddenly the bits were coming
together
to
realize that we might just survive this
thing on the 38th day
we'd been adrift six and a half weeks
now
and um
it's arraigned heavily that night and
they we were we were frightened for our
lives
then and we we often bailed
you know bailing water out of the out of
the dinghy all night and um one
particular now all three of us bailing
all night trying to keep the dingy
afloat
and we felt pretty good in spirit you
know we would their Seas were calming
and
we were talking about how many miles we
might make on the under oars
and how far off we were from Land we
were talking about dougal's kitchen that
was the cafe that we didn't invented to
talk about food
and
it's about four o'clock in the afternoon
doogle saw a ship
we we had forgotten almost that ships
could pick us up as well rescue was not
ruled out completely I know we'd sort of
convinced ourselves that we were on a
survival we were going to survive and
sail to America but now suddenly this
opportunity might present itself where
we could be rescued
we quickly cleared the cleared the decks
took the sale down and uh
Google held up first one Handler
and they didn't see that and then and
the ship was getting closer and closer
this time she would come within maybe a
mile
which is very close at sea
and um
we had one last hand flare left and and
Google we all studied the the dinghy as
he held up the the flare and the Flair
there was no wind although there was a
swell there was no wind and the the flux
of the uh Flair was dropping onto his
hand burning his hand but he still sort
of held it up and then he threw it
away
and that was the bit the Japanese
Helmsman saw
on the fishing boat
which was now as I say about about a
mile away
and he altered course
and we watched the alteration of course
not daring to believe that he was
altering course for us
we had no clothes on our clothes had
long gone
but my mother had saved us some little
rags
that we were to put on for being rescued
only my mum could think of that at a
time like this you know she said I don't
want you showing your you know your bare
bodies so you put these on you know and
the Toca Maru as she was called
approached
came alongside she was about 100 meters
away
maybe a bit closer than that actually
100 feet say
they threw a rope out to us a dirty oily
smelly rope
and I grabbed hold of that rope and uh
held it in my hand and looked at it and
realized that this rope was our Lifeline
to another life a life that we'd left
behind
so long ago it seemed it seemed like
we'd always been on that raft you know
and I I gripped it
and I didn't want them to go uh you know
I thought I'm not going to let go of
this rope because if I do they might
just not bother picking this up you know
like I know it's a weird idea but I
grabbed grabbed hold of that
and we couldn't make it fast because
there was nothing on the dinghy to make
it fast too
and gradually we closed with the
tokamaru and we were climbing onto the
deck
and touching the deck of the tokumaru
the wooden deck
and it was like a dream unfolding you
know Dougal said to the Japanese
they said can you save the dinghy
do you know it wasn't for the dinghy we
didn't want the dingy we wanted the food
that was in it which saved that food
which saved that water that was valuable
to us and the the captain of the fishing
boat said we've got food we've got food
on this ship
and Google we still didn't trust them
we wanted to save our food and so we
saved the dinghy and we pulled the
dinghy over onto the onto the the deck
of the tokumaru
you won't believe how small that dinghy
is it's a little cockle shell
but it's been our home for 38 days
towards your parents for taking you no
never
and you know I thank my dad every day of
my life now
for what he did
took it on this amazing adventure
that um just didn't turn out right but
it wasn't Douglas fault
and um
although my mum and dad never forgave
themselves for it
we forgave them straight away
I wrote a poem on the on the
on the raft
and I I finished the last line of it on
my mum did for me on on the ship on the
way home
and the
and I remember her bursting into tears
and
saying that she we should never have
done this and I said to her then I said
mum nobody died we've all got home
I said you know it wasn't the ending
that we wanted
but what what we did was great and
having survived that that was also great
you know it was a great feat that they'd
achieved my mum and dad together
my mum cared for us and the twins had a
little supper every night she made sure
that they had some extra food because
they were so young
life is never so
joyous
as when you're alive and you know you
could lose it at any moment
you know this just living can be very
Jewish when you know that you might not
be alive in that on the next wave
and we'd lost that you know now we were
going to face a new life
without the lucette
and without anything actually we were
not insured we were we'd lost everything
when the lucette went down
but uh that was the amazing
story
we were 25 miles out in Latitude 100
miles out in longitude from our position
with no navigational instruments
whatsoever so what happened out there in
the Pacific was fairly unique
it's a family The Experience out there
changed our lives forever because you
can't have those thoughts and it not
change you
and so even now
um and as I say it was 50 years ago last
year
a lot of the memories are still with me
about how we'd survived and
[Music]
you know
you make your own luck I know but uh
who were all so lucky
[Music]
and I remember unlocking my phone and
WhatsApp was on and I kind of closed
what's up and clicked on the camera
and the second I clicked the film
I saw what I guess the whole world saw
foreign